welcome to this video playing jammie
Dodger hadn't played him for a while he
was a very frequent opponent at times
let's see um oops not that modern be
naughty okay I go with this night g3
line the positions that i get with it
are usually really good so let's let's
play it again I like this Bishop af4
idea winning a tempo and setting up
Queen d2 Bishop h6 always feel that I
should exchange this bishop okay so I
manage that you know I mean I'm not a
big fan of the Benoni anyway but this
looks like unplayable to me I mean why
does a big Center and like this not even
have his his his counter play with them
with any dark squared bishop oke five
chicks and f5 is the normal way to to
play and I'm going to do that not think
too much about alternatives should give
white a very substantial advantage and a
good attack here on the king possible
ideas for the night d 4 + f6 also d6 is
coming and blacks counterplay is very
unclear
yeah not sure what he's doing now 98
maybe something like that yeah maybe
black has a way to play this but looks
very unattractive maybe this is a
relatively speaking good defense okay
should I just double on the F file or
something like 94 there's also d 6 which
is interesting you will put something to
f6 this is this is pretty much clear mmm
94 94 to g5 is also something that that
can be considered maybe this movement
not sure I want to I want to try to not
spend huge huge time I know that I tend
to really sink until hit to deep
thoughts in this kind of positions and
then at the end time I'm losing on time
okay so I is attacking d5 I actually
wanted to go nigh g5 here I see hmm I
see so maybe this wasn't the most
precise way to play okay see threatening
to take on f5 I can take here take on a
teen I this is prolly 94 knight takes
Bishop takes f5 maybe maybe he sir he's
doing that
huh
I take here maybe I should take I don't
really know 94 I have night age 5 I
think this looks very dangerous night
age 5 Queen 86 and probably very
dangerous is a huge understatement Wow
he allows that really night age 5 really
night h5 King age 8 Queen age 6 this is
just winning right where this is just
winning so he must take on g6 which
looks like wow yeah okay I'm going to
play this anyway let's not okay why is
why isn't he or isn't is this not
winning I mean maybe I'm just ask his
coloring g7 right so Queen age 6 you can
take on g6 I have Bishop d3 though is
all kinds of silly moves are like queen
g5
huh
how weird is that this is really
playable if I take and clay Bishop d3 he
might play King age 8 I have Queen age
six though which I think wins Chandler
Wow so I think you must take but then I
have to ship t3 really King h8 Queen age
six is really a win right f8 Hanks and
if they move to the eighth night it's
made under seven Wow okay if it takes
should be three for the pin yeah come on
this it's i can if i take you cannot
take on f5 because the rook hangs maybe
you can still play this position now
with a weird move like that
time warning yeah I know I know but I
don't know what to do this is probably
not the the most aggressive move yeah I
think I can go here with rook h3 cannot
move F form a queen before i got the
Queen trade and no ah he's got the Queen
trade ah that's terrible that's really
terrible now maybe maybe it's not that
that bad i have rookie amor and moves
like that but in general of course I
don't want to trade queens here
what a game yeah this is frustrating
that was never possible for black
absolutely never the scan of allowing
night h5 cannot believe this but I
couldn't I couldn't refute it over the
board yeah now this is just very weird
and have no time which is the main
problem what a weird position there's a
typical problem with those benoni
structures they are very often just
rubbish but but difficult to play you
are very often can can make mistakes in
those complicated positions yeah 95 and
my pieces are lost here and I have no
time yeah I can resign this why ah I
really lost my way here ok let's now
check how wide is winning so 9h 5k and
it's not wind this does not win you to
King g6 you can really do that isn't
chess unfair King g6 he can really play
Bishop d3 and f5 is winning for black
fif Bishop takes and he can really take
on age 5 yeah the computer is of course
perfect TM cannot argue with that so we
can really play this crap unbelievable
ok what I need to do is this Knight
takes and this is good for wine but
night h5 looked so tempting yeah it's
simply something like this is a good
sorry a good position for white Quincy
390 xe5 maybe I could have done
something better earlier queen is 3 as a
good move
or just the capture it's an interesting
way to play with Queen III attacking
both him yeah now this is a this is a
great position for white simply the comp
is already on +1 something wyd will play
d6 and just has an overwhelming position
yeah yeah as mentioned it's very often
not very good but to be tough to play or
here Queen g5 was was immediately
winning intending night age 50 what our
that's very easy yeah I felt there was
something very wrong with blacks
position but I didn't see it in the game
night at night h5 is simply deadly now
he has no defense if he goes there I
just play this and it's gone can just
play here here and blacks plex done yeah
and this is really can we can take 260 k
you went down and there is really no one
here this is unfair conference know when
Jake steaks which would be three yeah
this is probably better for white but
how do you play it exactly how do you
play it Bishop c2 is probably right and
somewhere around here okay queenie two
wins Kim it's very very very tricky with
the little time of course I overlooked
Queen D for this is the main problem I
absolutely don't want the Queen trade
with his King being her open so Queenie
to is the way to go cover the the night
maybe a check here and then continue
from from them it's also plus two so but
this is a big mistake along with the
Queen trade after that black is black is
immediately better he's got the center
and now his weird King position isn't
anymore so I've I've turned this around
from a very good position to a very bad
position which always feels a bit bad
because i think frankly speaking this
this is absolutely atrocious black
cannot allow the trade and allow f4 i
mean white I don't even need to SEK SEK
a pony if I want I can just build up
Group D 1 king age 1 and so on but if
I've is really the way to punish this
yeah but if you play nonsense afterwards
it doesn't help okay thanks for watching